rage to has you ripping and tearing
through bandits mutants and all sorts of
other bad dudes with beefy weapons and
superpowers in a post-apocalyptic world
but you may miss on some important
aspects like the best abilities to
upgrade the easiest way to take down
tougher enemies and how to find the good
stuff so here are 10 tips to get you
raging in peak form for Rage 2 parks are
these pods scattered across rage 2's
wasteland and they grant you new Nano
trade abilities and weapons both of
which are key to the best part of the
game
combat you'll get four arts marked on
your map at the outset but you'll have
to uncover the locations of the rest on
your own you can see their locations on
this map so pause if you need to slam is
the most effective and satisfying nano
trait in the game at first it works as a
simple ground-pound that does area of
effect damage and splatters enemies you
land on for a direct hit but as you
upgrade it slam can pull enemies towards
the center of your target area and do
even more damage this is one of the best
ways to eliminate a crowd
straight up rage to has one of the best
shotguns and video games it's impactful
feels matched by the amount of havoc it
wreaks on your enemies and although it's
not the most flashy gun in your arsenal
it's certainly the most functional
upgrading your shotgun will help you
tear through armored foes more
efficiently and reload much much faster
the vehicle controls and the twisty
roads of the wasteland make getting
around a bit of a pain so once you're
able to spawn in the icarus gyrocopter
in the vehicles menu there's no looking
back it's the most efficient way to get
places especially when you're trying to
knock out side quests or want to get
across the map fast plus you get nice
scenic views of the larger landscape
which is nice
remembering to - will save you in many
situations especially in fights against
huge mutants that can rush you quickly
or centuries with devastating laser
beams you only start with a single dash
on a short cooldown but you can upgrade
it to have a faster recovery time and be
able to dash twice at a time
cyber crushers are one of the few boss
type enemies in rh2 and it takes a bit
more than just a bunch of bullets to
take them down the best approach is to
launch a well-placed rocket to their
chest to get them to expose their felt
right tanks then use your assault rifle
to destroy those tanks after they're all
destroyed a few more rockets or a
shotgun shell barrage will finish them
off easily using focus doesn't just
enable you to use your Nano tried
abilities holding the focus button lets
you see enemies through walls which
helps you plan your initial attack this
is also handy for trying to find the
last few pesky bandits to clear out a
camp or to find those gas tanks you may
have missed at a pitstop side mission so
you try and do a side quest but can't
find the switch to reveal the last
explosive barrels at a pit stop or the
valves to lift up gates at a roadblock
just keep your eyes peeled for objects
splattered and neon pink paint since it
usually indicates important objects in
the world
this one's for the completionists out
there there are project upgrades that
will help you find our chests storage
containers and data pads by giving you a
UI element that indicates how close you
are to them since each side quest isn't
truly complete until you found all of
these in the corresponding area this
project perk will help ease the tedium
of searching for them now this might be
a cheap trick but tougher Authority
centuries can be knocked out easily once
you unlock the xerxes 3 heavy tank
century's retract to a defensive mode
when you enter the tank but since it
takes them a few seconds to do that you
have a window to hit them with a few
shots simply pop in and out of the tank
to catch them when they're vulnerable
while also avoiding their attacks
altogether so those are a few of our
basic tips to get you raging and rh2 if
you have any yourself leave them in
comments thanks for watching
[Music]